have you seen egoist successful people
totally the two largest companies in our
portfolio are headed by couples where
they both are aware of their
deficiencies they both cover for one
another they are the most uh anxiety
ridden of them of like am I doing good
enough is this right I feel like we
should be doing more like paranoia
around improving the product the service
the culture the business overall whereas
the more ego-driven ones want to reflect
more of the greatness of the business
onto themselves they want to take more
of the credit they can't attract Talent
at scale because only going to
work for